today on the matt wall show a hardcore
porn star gets booted from an event for
conservative teens and many
conservatives have a problem with this
for a variety of ludicrous reasons we'll
discuss also five headlines
protests once again turn violent at we
spa in los angeles when antifa shows up
to defend a man's right to disrobe in
the women's locker room
also cnn gets called out live on the air
by a cnn guest and it's pretty glorious
we'll play that for you
and camille harris says it is your
biblical duty to get vaccinated
plus in our daily cancellation we'll
talk about the ever-growing
inappropriately named
child-free movement child-free movement
they call it all of that and more today
on the matt walsh show
before we get started here today i want
to tell you very important information
about our sponsor relief band you know i
have struggled with motion sickness car
sickness my entire life i can think back
to being a kid
you know sitting in the back of the van
on long car trips vacations
a couple of occasions vomiting all over
the place the whole the whole van
reeks of vomit this is more information
than you need
and if it's making you nauseous hearing
all this information that's why you need
relief band relief band is the number
one fda cleared anti-nausea wristband
that's been clinically proven to quickly
relieve and effectively prevent nausea
and vomiting associated with motion
sickness
anxiety migraine hangover morning
sickness uh
too and for too much information from a
podcast host many other
sources the product is 100 drug-free
non-drowsy provides all natural relief
with zero side effects for as long as
needed the technology was originally
developed over 20 years ago in hospitals
to relieve nausea from patients but now
it is available to the masses through
relief band you can ensure that nausea
is never the reason to miss out on
life's important moments
by going to reliefband.com relief ban
has an exclusive offer just for matt
walsh listeners
if you go to reliefband.com and use
promo code walsh you'll get 20
off plus free shipping and a no
questions asked 30-day money-back
guarantee
go to r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d com
for use promo code walsh for 20 off you
know if i wanted to demonstrate the dire
state of conservatism today i would
probably need to only point to this one
fact
there is a woman who calls herself a
conservative porn star
and she has legions of quote unquote
conservative
fans including prominent conservatives
and media
brandy love is her name she's 48 years
old somehow making the whole thing even
more embarrassing and pathetic
and along with posting hardcore porn
online including on twitter where users
as young as 13
can easily access it she's also
fashioned herself as a champion of the
conservative cause
in which role she has authored a few
editorials that have been published by
the federalist
i don't know i'm not aware of any other
conservative activism she's done but
there's that
now i was unaware of this person's
existence blissfully so i might add
until this past weekend when controversy
was ignited by brandy love's attendance
at turning point usa's
student action summit tpusa that's
charlie cook
kirk's organization and this is their
conference that they do every year for
students that's what they call the
student action summit right there in the
name
now love a real name tracy livermore
initially showed up at the press
conference at the conference rather
four conservative high school and
college students with a vip badge
the impression that this gave of course
and the way it was reported on social
media and by some outlets like newsweek
is that she was specifically invited or
welcomed
by tpusa and that's why she had the vip
badge now that wasn't the case
she purchased the vip ticket showed up
on her own accord
and began posting to her twitter to her
twitter page in between photos of her
genitals and so forth
there were also pictures of her walking
around the event posing in front of fox
news banners
and expressing her enjoyment at being
around so many quote young conservatives
tpusa however did not enjoy having her
as much as she enjoyed being there
once the event uh organizers realized
who she was
and what she did and why she was there
they kindly asked her to leave
and this is how they explain that
decision to newsweek this is what they
said
quote turning point usa this is
according to the
tpusa spokesman turning point usa did
not block miss love from its student
event
because of backlash tpusa did so in
keeping with its standard operating
procedures to not involve
porn brands influencers or personalities
that post
or publish sexually explicit and
pornographic content
a few concerned parents rightly alerted
us to the extremely pornographic nature
of her social media posts
and event leadership immediately took
the appropriate steps in keeping with
the best interests of the minors present
at the event
furthermore miss love purchased an adult
vip ticket she was not invited nor was
her attendant somehow requested by the
organization
the bottom line is that it is simply not
appropriate for a porn star to be
actively posting images
at an event with 15 and 16 year olds
present in conjunction with graphic
pornography
tpusa makes no apology for this a
position which should not be
controversial especially
when minors are involved parents deserve
this type of assurance and tpuso intends
on giving them that confidence any
controversy is purely contrived
all right that's the whole statement
everything that you just heard there
could not possibly be more reasonable
they're holding an event for
conservative teenagers
they don't wish to welcome a vip guest
who is actively in the hardcore porn
business
and who will post images of herself at
the event alongside images of her vagina
they also don't wish to become a forum
for a cyber prostitute
which is what a porn star is to directly
promote her business to minors or to
anyone else at their event
this is again a conservative conference
for students
tracy livermore put them in an
uncomfortable position by choosing to
show up without any warning without
asking without checking with them first
and the embarrassment of getting kicked
out on her ass is therefore her own
fault
you don't even have to be anti-porn to
understand the basic concept here
and to recognize who the bad guy in the
situation is
but many on the right have struggled to
understand this
although livermore is clearly 100 to
blame
and tpusa did absolutely nothing wrong
and conducted itself
well in this case still so many
conservatives felt otherwise
the the organization is being attacked
today from the rights
for daring to make a 48 year old
hardcore porn star
feel unwelcome at their event for
conservative teens
prominent conservatives have jumped on
the the dog pile as well but ben
dominus who's the co-founder of the
federalist he's also husband of
meghan mccain he tweeted quote i'm
disappointed that tpusa kicked out
brandy love for no reason whatsoever
she's a florida conservative
businesswoman
who loves america the right has an
opportunity to be the big tent party
don't be a bunch of prudes
businesswoman doing a lot of work in
that sentence i think
nick circe who's a conservative actor
with a large following also defended
livermore arguing that
you aren't being like jesus if you agree
with tp usa on its decision
apparently jesus thinks that 48 year old
hardcore porn stars
should totally be vip guests at
conferences for teenagers
at least we should say nick has made
that assumption about jesus christ and
is comfortable
putting those words into his mouth these
arguments were echoed on social media by
many on the right
including livermore herself where she
spent the following
day or two painting herself as the
victim complaining about
how she was treated quoting the bible in
her own defense
and arguing that conservatives who
oppose pornography
or the attendance of a pornographer at a
conservative student conference
are jackasses fools prudes etc
she also posted more pictures of her
genitals so
in between quoting the bible she's
posting pictures of her genitals no
problem there
now let's try to um sort through this
and inject a little bit of sanity into
the proceedings if we can
and to that end a few points i think
need to be made
number one to reiterate
just considering the business and pr
concerns here alone
it is perfectly understandable that a
conservative activist group
that works with minors would not want a
woman with her porn star stage name on
her vip
pass walking around the place taking
pictures and meeting quote
fans if livermore had any respect for
anyone
and cared about anything or anyone but
herself she would have contacted tp usa
ahead of time
anticipating the uncomfortable position
she might be putting them in
and asked them if if she could attend
she didn't take this step and the fact
that she didn't only proves that she
couldn't care less how her presence
impacts the event or the organization
that's holding it
which is just one more reason why that
organization has no obligation
to let her stay here's a basic concept
if you choose to make your living by
having sex on camera
and posting pictures of your genitals on
social media
if that's how you choose that's what you
choose to do
you can't be offended when people don't
want to be associated with you
it's not as though you were born a porn
star
this isn't a genetic defect it's not a
biological identity it's not your race
or ethnicity
no i'm being discriminated against no
people are reacting to your choices
sweetheart you also aren't a desperate
poor
sex trafficked 18 year old you're a 48
year old woman
who has chosen to make a lot of money
this way doing very well for yourself
you may say you have the right to
prostitute yourself online for money and
you do
legally according to our laws at the
moment
but uh people and organizations also
have the right to not want to associate
with you
that doesn't make you a victim grow up
number two this all bleeds i think into
a broader conversation about
conservatism and and what it stands for
or doesn't stand for and as this
incident demonstrates
though we knew this already um there are
some conservatives
many i think who think that uh
conservatism should embrace
and defend the normalization of hardcore
pornography
to a lot of conservatives today uh if if
you
not only should you defend hardcore
pornography but it's like absurd if you
don't it's ridiculous not to
you're just a prude in fact if you don't
think that a hardcore porn star
should be at an event for conservative
16 year olds
you're prude according to conservatives
they don't think that being conservative
should necessarily mean um that that you
know we have to be critics of the porn
industry
or even of a porn star showing up at an
event like this of course 40 years ago
this would not have been a discussion
you wouldn't have been able to find any
self-proclaimed conservative anywhere
who would defend hardcore porn in
principle as a thing fully in keeping
with conservative values as just a
legitimate form of business that's all
now many conservatives will do just that
because the left has shifted the whole
culture in its direction
so thoroughly and dramatically that
conservatives will adopt radically
leftist positions
while imagining that they're opposing
the left in the process
you might compare it i guess to the
situation encountered by
early arctic explorers attempting to
reach the north pole
they would walk for miles imagining that
they're going north
but the ice beneath them was drifting
south
so they were going one way while the
ground they stood on went the other
well in our culture the ground we stand
on stand on drifts ever left which means
that
if your version of being right wing is
simply to be slightly to the right of
what qualifies right now as left wing
then you will at best be the right wing
of the left wing
which is what a lot of the people on the
right really are
they are the right wing of america's
left wing
that's why you got to be philosophically
and ideologically grounded
in something deeper
if if all if if your grounding
[Music]
doesn't go any deeper than the ice
you're standing on
then when that whole chunk is shifting
you're shifting along with it
along with the cultural tide
uh all of the conservatives who imagine
that they're conserving something
while embracing what what would have
been considered radical
by the left 20 years ago are evidence of
this problem
here's the point the normalization of
sexual degeneracy
is a leftist position
and uh and i'll in fact i'll amend that
a little bit
it's not only a leftist position it is
in fact
the principal leftist position
it's the main thing that they're trying
to do
it's the primary thing that animates
them is the normalization of sexual
degeneracy
you cannot fight leftists while
embracing
their primary foundational doctrine
you're agreeing with them on the thing
that they consider to be
the most important thing
which is the normalization of sexual
degeneracy
and the idea that you know sexually you
should be able to do whatever you want
and live however you want and uh
not only should you be able to but it
should be celebrated and accepted by
everyone
you cannot fight the left you can't
really stand for anything least of all
freedom or whatever you think you're
standing for
if you've abandoned moral truth
if conservatism seeks to conserve
anything
that's what it has to conserve right
first and foremost
truth of all kinds moral truth included
and biological truth we should note
but when you look at what's happened in
conservatism even just over the last
couple months
we've had self-proclaimed conservatives
embracing caitlyn jenner
and self-proclaimed conservatives a lot
of them the same ones
uh now saying oh yeah have hardcore porn
stars at the
conservative events let's prove how cool
we are
a total abandonment of moral truth and
biological truth of truth of all kinds
and then where are you left what do you
think you're doing exactly
what's the ne what's the next step here
okay the goal is to let's defeat the
left step one
abandon moral truth step two abandon
biological truth
and then what victory okay then we got
step
three question marks step four victory
what goes in step three there
you've joined them you've given them
everything
you imbecile you've given them
everything they want
and you'll oppose them now because uh
well yeah we give them everything that
matters we've given them truth we've
given them morality
we've adopted their fundamental outlook
on life
but we believe in lower taxes
what i would like for someone to do
is explain
break it down for me what exactly are
you conserving
what are you trying to conserve
if not truth first and foremost
and if you can't come up with an answer
to that then i would suggest that you
and i
are not even on the same side
now let's get to our five headlines
and uh one last note on that i should
also mention that uh brandy love it has
come to my attention
tracy livermore brandie uh sent out a
tweet and and she said that uh
that i have lost her she said matt walsh
has lost me
well no i i didn't lose you because we
we were never
on the same side at all so there was no
there's no there's no loss here
oh no i've lost the hardcore porn star
i've lost a 48 year old woman
selling her body on the internet what a
what a great tragedy
all right um let's go here number one
michael wolff who's an author uh he was
hawking his i think his new anti-trump
book
that he has out which which i have no
interest in but i do have interest in
this he was on cnn
and uh with the baked potato himself
brian stelter
uh and it's kind of a long clip we're
gonna play the whole thing because this
is this is just great
um he started attacking brian stelzer
and cnn right to his face
on the air and it's uh simply wonderful
let's watch
i think the media has done a terrible
job on this i think
you yourself um you know why you're a
nice guy you know you're full of
sanctimony
um you know you become part of one of
the parts of the problem of the media
you know you come on here and you and
you have a um
um you know a monopoly on truth you know
you know
exactly how things are supposed to be
done um
you know you are why one of the reasons
people can't stay in the media
sorry you're cracking me up it's your
fault
you know people have genuine problems
with it with
with the media the media doesn't get the
story right
the media exists in its own bubble
um that's true i agree you uh
um you know you gotta stop i mean that
last segment that
that that i just had to listen to of all
of the people saying the same old stuff
also you're incredibly repetitive it's
week after week i mean you're the flip
side of of
of of donald trump um you know fake news
and you say virtuous news you know i
they're they're not just figure out what
is real i mean yeah we're listening
well figuring out yeah figuring out what
is real is not so
is not so uh it's not so easy and and
you know most people don't want to turn
to brian stelter to tell us what's real
i'm sorry i
what what is with uh first of all
they all do this camille harris does it
the laugh they all do when they're being
called out or they're in an
uncomfortable situation
uh the the the nervous laughter that
goes piece of paper
the nervous laughter that they do it's
really awkward and it comes off
you know it's one thing if you have
nervous laughter is is an instinct that
people have is kind of a reflex
but the laughter you hear from from
stelter there just like with with harris
it's not a reflex it comes off as
as a something intentional they're doing
a deflection and i don't think it works
in their favor
but of course everything that he said
that i don't think there's any further
commentary needed to be added there
uh i think everything you said there was
obviously correct all right next we have
there were more protests
that uh we spa in los angeles over the
weekend people upset that the spa
is uh allowing men to show their penises
to young girls
uh something that by the way just give
it a couple more years and a lot of
conservatives are going to be defending
this as well if they're not already
just just a few more years probably by
2025 or so if not sooner i might be a
little bit
i'm being optimistic thinking it'll take
that long
you'll have a conservative saying well i
mean of course men can disrobe in front
of uh young girls in locker rooms but
not outside of the locker room
i i'll put my foot down there go in the
locker room and do that
and expose yourself well only only the
left only the degenerate leftists
think that men can disrupt anywhere they
want
no no you have to follow the women and
the girls into the locker room and then
disrobe
that's the conservative position
uh but as it stands right now most
people on the right are seem to be on
the same page that uh
men should not be exposing them
themselves to
uh young girls or or women of any of any
age um
and so that's the that's why the
protests were happening antifa showed up
and uh got violent as always and to say
that antifa showed up and things became
violent
it's sort of redundant now unnecessary
but this is how the media is
covering this story uh this is from the
guardian now it says dozens of people
have been arrested in los angeles
following a chaotic and at times violent
demonstration by anti-transgender
protesters
who targeted a koreatown spa that has a
trans-inclusive policy allowing trans
women
to use the women's facilities saturday
marked the second weekend of violent
protests this month in the streets
around
we spa a neighborhood business that has
found itself on the heart of a
right-wing media storm
over an alleged incident in which a
customer filmed herself complaining
about a trans woman in the women's area
of the spa
the far-right protesters called for a
boycott of
wii spa and chanted baseless claims
about pedophilia
as women carrying signs reading protect
female spaces
and it's worse in women's shelters
marched alongside men wearing helmets
and masks that covered their faces
baseless claims of pedophilia
well you're you're admitting in the
article itself
that men you call them trans women but
they're men
um are disrobing
in the locker room and there are young
girls in there so i wouldn't call this
baseless at all
a man disrobing and uh showing his
genitals to a young girl that's
the sexual harassment of a young child
and yes i would i would i would put that
in the category of pedophilia
not sure how else to do how else to
describe it
and it's not just this one woman we
should remember
there's the woman who filmed herself
complaining and she's the one who
sparked all of this because she took a
stand
courageously so and i don't use that
word lightly
to be in los angeles of all places uh
and to be a woman taking a stand against
this what we see how antifa reacts to
that
you're putting yourself in line for
public shame you're gonna be
accused of being a bigot and a
transphobe and all this kind of stuff
and potentially even physical violence
so the woman who's who sparked all of
this i think is a
is a true she acted heroic she's a true
hero she acted heroically
but she's not the only one we also
played last week there was another woman
sharing her experience
in the exact same spa she said she was
sitting in the hot tub with her
six-year-old daughter and
none of the girls or women in the locker
room are wearing clothing this is a
korea spa korean spots apparently what
they do there
uh and then a man walks in takes his
clothes off
you know sitting on the edge of the hot
tub spreading his legs
showing his genitals to a six-year-old
girl
i don't know i don't know how else to
categorize that
if not pedophilia and she's not the only
one
i also shared with you going back to
2018 there was a yelp review posted in
2018.
it sounded like this was posted
yesterday claiming that they have posted
in 2018 of someone sharing
the same kind of experience and
complaining about it one into the locker
room
there was a guy disrobing talking about
his sexual exploits with women
um and so that's what's happening but
according to the guardian
and really almost everyone else in the
media that's covered this
all of these women complaining
even though the second one we mentioned
with the second video
she was of a democrat she goes to gay
pride parades
she said but now they're all far right
if you don't want your six-year-old
daughter
to be exposed to a man's penis then
you're
a far-right protester and a white
supremacist even
read a little bit more here it says the
chants and signs in los angeles on
saturday highlighted the convergence of
anti-trans activism with other strains
of far-right activism
many demonstrators chanted save our
children a slogan taken up by q anon
conspiracy theorists
this is what this is one of the latest
uh innovations of
media propaganda here that save our
children people who speak out
saying save our children protect our
children now that's it's not just
far right that's a conspiracy that
you're a q anon conspiracy theorist
if you want to protect our children
which means that a lot of us i mean i i
guess i've been a q a on conspiracy
there
way before q anon existed
go to the march for life tons of signs
with with words to that effect of
protect our children save our children
guess we were all pioneers we we
invented the q anon conspiracy theory
years before it even existed um
other demonstrators wore shirts pledging
to murder left-wing activists with
reference to right-wing death squads and
chile in the 1970s
this is the media's claim by the way
that i'd like to see proof that that
shirt was worn according to multiple
protesters arthur schaefer the leader of
the california chapter of an
anti-lgbt hate group arrived early to
protest outside we spa and took refuge
behind a line of police officers as
trans rights protesters heckled him
um it's it's also interesting now
louis lois beckett is a guardian
reporter i'm not sure if she's the same
one who wrote this report
but she was there and uh talking about
her experiences and she tweeted this she
says
just got thrown to the ground by
right-wing anti-pedophile protesters as
a crowd converged on me and chased me
they threw water at me and screamed
about jesus and said to grab my phone
police would not let me through the
police line but after i got thrown on
the ground
they did now what's what's interesting
there
is uh
she also is using this phrase that well
they're anti-pedophile protesters
and you're not so you're using
anti-pedophile
in a in a in a pejorative way that's the
tone here
he's far-right anti-pedophile protesters
well let me just say right now as absurd
as it is
to brand this a right-wing position i'll
take it
as a member of the far right myself
professionally so i i'll take that if
you want to give that to us
i'll take it sure yeah we're
okay we're the anti-pedophile side fine
and you're not i mean we already know
that but if you if you want to just come
out and admit that then uh then that's
perfectly fine with me
at least we're finally getting our cards
on the table i suppose which is nice
all right moving on here camila harris
uh she had some thoughts over the
weekend
about vaccines and the bible let's take
a listen to that
i do believe that the act of getting
vaccinated
is the very essence
the very essence of what the bible tells
us when it says
love thy neighbor right
because what we know is one can ask well
who is one's neighbor is it the person
who lives to my left lives to my right
i know them may borrow a cup of sugar
right um but what we know it means when
we talk about love thy neighbor
is that yes it may be the person next
door
and it may be the man on the side of the
road
and it may be a perfect stranger
and in the face of that stranger you see
a friend that's what this is about
and so by getting vaccinated you are
loving your neighbor
you know if she's being honest though
uh if she's being totally honest the
bible quote that really gets her message
about vaccines across
the bible quote that really conveys
um her point about about vaccines i
would say it's more maybe an exodus
i am the lord thy god thou shalt have no
other gods before me
that's the bible quote and that's that's
because that's what the government is
saying to us the government is god
saying we we're we're telling you to do
this
and that's why you should do it
you know if they were serious about
convincing people to get vaccinated
it's going to take for one thing
humility
okay it's going gonna take two things
you're gonna have to actually take these
objections seriously
and treat them with respect treat the
people with respect
and also demonstrate some humility and
both of these things sincerity and
humility
this is outside the grasp of someone
like male harris
or anyone in the by administration or
any of these smarmy bastards in the
media
mocking those who haven't gotten
vaccinated or accusing them of
you know being mass murderers and
basically terrorists
that's not going to do it if you really
cared you would drop that whole act
completely
spitting bible quotes especially coming
from camila harris of all people
avidly pro-abortion huge fan of of
of babies being slaughtered by the
millions in the womb this is not someone
who cares what the bible has to say
so if you really wanted to that's what
you would do
and you would start by saying hey listen
uh a lot of public officials from the
very beginning
have not been honest about this there's
been
there's been contradictory uh
conflicting pronouncements that have
been made about coronavirus
from the very beginning we made a lot of
mistakes from the very beginning
we shut down whole businesses and
industries that didn't need to be shut
down
we foisted all this on our kids which
was unnecessary we took them out of
school
which we didn't need to do it caused a
lot of damage
and that's why people don't trust us and
and i don't blame them for not trusting
us
they're not stupid for not trusting us
however
they should still get vaccinated because
blah blah blah and then you make your
pitch
and you apologize for the way that this
has been handled
acknowledging that you have given people
a reason not to trust you
that is the primary reason the people
who are not getting vaccinated
either they have looked at the
at the facts and just decided that this
is not something they feel like they
need
oftentimes because they're not in a high
risk category for for
for coronavirus and so they figure well
i just don't need this
um or and maybe it's both of these
things they just don't trust
any of the people on tv telling them to
do it
and bringing in pop stars and juveniles
saying backs that ass up
that doesn't help much either
but again that's outside their capacity
they can't demonstrate humility so
they're gonna keep hectoring
and scolding and uh it won't make a
difference
you're not gonna you're not gonna
convince one single person that way not
one
um and this isn't going to help either
from the daily mail says l.a county's
reinstated indoor mask
wearing mandate went into effect today
as the indian delta variant threatens to
halt progress across the coronavirus
across the country
against the coronavirus across the
country the spread of the highly
contagious strain which originated in
india has already pushed
new infections up to 26 thousand
nationwide an increase of 69
on a seven-day moving average compared
to one a week earlier nearly every state
witnessed a rise in infections in the
last week and cdc data shows the delta
variant
is responsible for about 60 of these
cases
the reinstatement of indoor mask wearing
in la came after the county saw a 700
increase
in its positivity rate over the past
month according to health officials with
the unvaccinated accounting for
all hospitalizations well if you're
trying to push vac
vaccines this isn't helping either
telling people they have to go get put
their masks on again
that's not going to help and yeah we're
hearing how cases are up and more and
more
even people are vaccinated are getting
the dreaded delta strain
how let me ask you this how many of the
vaccinated people
or the people who have immunity one way
or another even if it's from prior
infection
of the immune people how many of them
are getting seriously sick from the
delta variant
or dying from it none is the answer like
zero or very close to zero yeah exactly
so what you're going to hear when this
with this new um
with this new attempt at pushing the
coveted panic porn
they're going to drop well we know for
the last year and a half it was nothing
but they were telling us about
deaths they were telling us about
hospitalization rates people in the icu
and so on
you're going to notice something they're
not going to be talking about that
anymore you're not going to hear much
about deaths because there aren't a lot
of deaths happening
thank god right now instead they're
going to talk only about cases
and they're not going to mention that a
great number of these cases are just
really mild infections and not a big
deal
because they're happening in people who
have already had prior immunity
all right next this is uh also from the
guardian
a lot of british media today probably
way too much i didn't plan it this way
but that's the way it happened
uh it says britney spears has refused to
perform again while her
father retains control over her career
and said the conservatorship
she has been under for 13 years has
killed my dreams
in quotes her remarks at a lengthy
instagram post were the latest in a
series of emotional public comments
about conservatorship that controls her
personal and financial affairs and
which she has begged to be brought to an
end uh she wrote quote i'm not going to
be performing on any stages any time
soon with my dad
handling what i wear say do or think um
and also she uh appointed a new lawyer
to represent her in a bid to bring the
conservative
conservatorship to an end and she was
allowed by a judge to appoint her
own lawyer you know i haven't said
anything about the britney spears story
even though people seem to care very
deeply about it my wife cares deeply
about it
i was talking about to her about this on
the way home from church yesterday
and uh because she gives me the britney
spears update like every night
even though i don't ask but she's very
invested in this story as well and so i
was talking to my wife about it and she
was bringing up
and then and i i i as i often do i
pivoted ever the conversation back to
aliens
don't don't ask how i made that
connection but that's what i normal
that's usually my move
if i'm not interested in a conversation
i'm just going to pivot it and say yeah
but what about aliens though
um so i understand people care about
this but but here's my general take on
it
two things the one is
i'm not exactly sure why this case
matters as as much
as it seems to matter to a lot of people
even if she is suffering
in injustice which it sounds like there
are many unjust things that happen to
britney spears
uh having an iud forced on her certainly
i oppose that
absolutely on moral grounds but
um there are many injustices happening
in the world
and such intense focus has been placed
on this
but i think more more to the point
and i don't know how else to put this
except except this way
what if britney spears is actually
insane though
like we seem to have ruled out that
possibility
if she's if she's actually in i don't
know i don't know what her mental health
can
situation is um
but if she's actually psychotic or
insane or something
then that's probably why the
conservatorship was put in place to
begin with
it doesn't justify everything that's
been done under the guiseley
conservatorship
uh necessarily but that's why it's there
so all the protesters
who for months or years now some of them
showing up at the courtroom demanding
take the conservative
ship off like do you know something
about britney spears
spears's mental health situation
that the people involved in this case
the judges and everyone don't know
what information do you have because
what you're saying is no just take it
off
but what if she really is not competent
is not able to handle her own affairs
are are you sure that's not the case are
are is this a
is this a protest against the very
concept of a conservatorship
i mean that's one thing i wouldn't agree
with that i think they do have their
place
if someone is truly incompetent
truly insane
then that's the place again it doesn't
justify everything that is done
under that guise but in principle that's
why conservatorships exist
so that's my that's my issue now i could
think back i i haven't followed bernie
spears that closely but i can think back
over the years especially going back
when i guess when the conservatorship
was placed on her
it was pretty clear from the way she was
acting in public that this is
not a mentally healthy woman
and the sad thing is it's not her fault
it's not anyone's fault if they have
mental health problems
and in her case when you take someone at
the age of 15 or 16
and you turn them into a child star
and you overtly sexualize them
as was done to her then you're
destroying them
mentally causing immense psychological
damage and we've seen this with almost
every child star that's ever existed
almost none of them turn out okay
so it's a tragic story a tragic case of
course not her fault but even so
i think that that's that's a question
that seems to be sidestepped here
oh no take the conservatorship ship off
well okay but
what what do you know about her mental
health
all right finally um going back to
britain yet again but this is from the
new york post at least
it says american kids are binge watching
so much of the british cartoon peppa pig
that they're developing english accents
and
even using words like tele and ready
steady go
the so-called peppa effect had already
led kids in the u.s to mimic the star
swine with
uk produced peppa pig and all that extra
telly time during coven 19 restrictions
appears to be making the phenomenon
more widespread um
that's the claim anyway that kids are
going around speaking with british
accents
and using british words because they're
watching so much peppa pig
now i have been this might be a little
bit off-brand you might not expect this
um but i've been a peppa pig apologist
for years i think it's a it's a whole
wholesome show there's no woke stuff as
far as i know
and i kind of dread saying that because
i just know someone in the comments now
is going to say oh no they just they
just had an episode with a transgender
donkey last last sunday
as far as i know there's no woke stuff
wholesome show for kids
but my main thing is um it's not
aggressively obnoxious and loud
and almost every children show it's
impossible to be in the same room with
it
because it's just loud noises bright
colors
in your face
all the time really really
stupid and obnoxious most of the time
when we talk about children's television
or children's entertainment that's
that's a short way of that shorthand for
stupid aggressive obnoxious and loud
and peppa pig is not that
so of all the shows that my kids could
put on i'd say okay well just put on
peppa
i can i can be in the same room as it
better than paw patrol or one of these
other shows
but now i see that it's a plot by the
damn brits um
a trojan horse it's revenge for 1776.
they're taking our children from us it's
like a form of kidnapping
so yet another thing that i thought was
okay and safe
proves not to be real tragedy all right
moving on to reading the youtube
comments
um dna studio says having matt read my
comment is like winning the lottery but
without the money
so it's like winning the lotto except
nothing like winning the lotto is what
you're saying
you might as well say it's it's it's a
buffet but without the food
isn't the money the whole point of
winning the lottery
winning a lottery and then finding out
that there's no money would be just
would be
a great disappointment and so what
you're actually saying is that me
reading your comment was a huge
disappointment you're banned from the
show
austin says uh the only language that's
violence is matt trying to pronounce
kran
there are lots of comments about my
pronunciation of koran once again i am
discriminated against for my baltimore
accent okay this is the way
we say the word once again i meant to
feel unsafe and unwanted on my own show
how do you want me to pronounce it
crayon
hey kids get your crayons off the couch
is that what you want
crayon is that what you want
sorry i'm getting a little speaking of
aggressive
crayons probably aren't worth this much
energy uh florida said florida politics
central says
matt walsh a day keeps the lefties away
that effect
check fact check you on that also
because listening or
to or certainly sharing anything i say
will not keep the lefties away
i still want you to share it but fair
warning
that's not gonna do it uh the good texan
says i don't use the word
cis male or cis female because i don't
like to marginalize normal people
well i i think you you say that slightly
tongue-in-cheek but
that is exactly the point of those terms
in fact
that is that is actually what those
terms do and that's why i don't use the
terms either unless i'm quoting somebody
but that's the point we call someone a a
biological
a man who acts like a man and
identifies as a man we say he's a cis
male
and the idea is to make being a normal
man
just one variety
one variety
among a whole cornucopia of legitimate
varieties that's the idea
now being a cis male that's not a
variety or a type
or an option everyone is a cis male in
the fact that
every man is a cis male and the fact
that you're that's just what you are
there's no other option
dylan says sweet baby gang is now
trending up on google good job not
talking about it matt
uh it is training on google that's good
news and also
uh the petition i haven't last i checked
was a few days ago but i think we're up
to a thousand
over a thousand now i have to look again
certainly over a thousand signatures on
the sweet baby gang petition
uh this is this is one of the most
inspiring grassroots
movements that i've ever been a part of
the sweet baby gang you know together
we can work wonders at least we can get
a t-shirt on sale
hopefully we'll see it's no secret that
trust in the media has reached an
all-time low you keep thinking it
couldn't get any lower and somehow it
does
and that's because of all the lies the
misinformation
uh propaganda fake news that you get yet
somehow
the media continues to dominate the
conversation that's why we're bringing
you an alternative news podcast to start
your day
from the daily wires newsroom comes
morning wire a daily news show that
values your time and the truth brought
to you by daily wire editor-in-chief
john bickley and co-host georgia howe
morningwire will wake you up with the
latest developments in politics sports
culture and education all with a heavy
emphasis
on the facts it's available today so
subscribe now to morningwire on apple
podcast spotify and everywhere you
listen to podcasts
so you don't miss a second of it and
also i got to tell you that next tuesday
july 27th is the release of ben
shapiro's newest book the authoritarian
moment and it'll be a huge event because
ben will be doing a live stream book
signing
next tuesday so pre-order your signed
copy now at dailywire.com
ben when you do you'll be asked to type
in a question at checkout
then you can catch tuesday's live
signing to see if he answers your
question
and you can watch him sign your book
right there on the spot so get your copy
at dailywire.com ben right now so you
don't miss out now let's get to our
daily cancellation
if there's one thing that really turns
our media on
it's the extinction of the human race
our media is perhaps more than anything
anti-human at least anti-most humans as
far as humans go
they like themselves and believe that
they themselves should continue existing
it's all the other humans especially
future generations of humans
that they aren't so sure about and
that's why the media is always eager for
any excuse to celebrate the so-called
child free movement on that end here's
an article a recent article from
today.com it says
laura lavoy knew all her life she didn't
want to have children now 46
she never felt that draw she said part
of part of a growing
u.s population opting out of parenthood
a new study finds child free people are
as happy as parents with the office
authors surprised by just how many men
and women indicated they didn't want to
have kids it's part of a larger trend of
americans having fewer children in
general
the us birth rate fell to a record low
last year and there could be
three hundred thousand to five hundred
thousand fewer births in 2021 according
to some estimates
for lavoy there were many reasons to
choose to be child free
quote the most important is that i just
don't want to raise children it's not
just
it's just not something that has ever
appealed to me i don't want to be
responsible for another human being in
that way
lavoy a writer who lives in asheville
north carolina told today
but i also really like traveling i like
adventure
ever sitting in the same spot for very
long and just kind of lifestyle things
that don't really fit with having a
child
well yeah there's a word for that it's
called being superficial
and materialistic and selfish so that's
three words i suppose
it'd be a lot easier and get to the
point much quicker if these people would
just say that
to say i'm materialistic and selfish and
that's how i want to live my life
also i must note here you're not an
adventurer
because you spend thousands of dollars
to go to different tourist spots around
the globe
you want an adventure take four kids to
the grocery store okay adventure awaits
right down the street if you do that
that qualifies his adventure at least as
much as flying down to cancun
and drinking 27 cocktails in a tourist
resort
now the cancun trip may be more relaxing
i admit
but i'm just tired of these childless
couples acting like
they're exploring the amazon bragging
about their adventures
when they're being herded like cattle
from one tourist spot to the next
anyway back to the article it says her
husband feels the same way she said
they've been together 26 years and both
agreed they didn't want to have children
they've discussed it over the years but
knew the answer would always be the same
she noted
over a quarter of adults 27 identified
as child
free in the new study 27 percent um the
number dramatically exceeds previous
estimates of two to nine percent
reported by earlier studies the authors
said more than a third of child free
people 35
were in a partnered relationship
suggesting couples who don't want
children
quote represent an important type of
family they added
do they though i mean if you get married
and choose not to have kids
your family really isn't important in a
broader sense i mean it's important to
you
but not to anyone else your family of
two could break apart any time and it
would have literally no effect on
society in the slightest
when you both die after after long there
will be no trace that
you ever existed except for your
headstone or that your relationship
existed
families with children on the other hand
are bearing the weight of the future on
our shoulders if our families break
apart
the consequences to society are immense
and catastrophic as we've seen
if we stay together though and raise our
kids well we've bestowed an immeasurable
blessing onto civilization
i can see how that qualifies as
important i don't see how mr and mrs
lavoy down in cancun opting for nicer
vacations and nicer cars
rather than propagating the human
species are doing anything important for
civilization
except by contributing to our
civilization's decline which i guess is
certainly consequential
if in a negative way now important to
mention here also um
the article in the study draw a
distinction between so-called child-free
couples
and childless couples childless people
are those who want children but haven't
had them yet or can't have them for
whatever reason
child free people are those who've
chosen not to have them and not to adopt
so everything i'm saying here applies
only to the latter to child free
people who want children but can't have
them have been given
a great burden and i i feel sorry for
them the good news is that their desire
for
children shows that they're not
self-centered
you know and they have a giving heart
and that's the pain when you're
childless and don't want to be
um that you have a giving heart and
you're not self-centered
and you want to pour this love into a
family
but you can't have one for whatever
reason
but as i said the good news is that
they'll find in
other ways to contribute to society to
society and to make a positive impact
because that's what selfless giving
people do the people like
the lavoies are a different story
completely and that's who we're talking
about here and as far as they go
i think two points should be made first
of all
it doesn't make sense or at least
doesn't convey very much
to say that child free people are just
as happy as parents
only parents can really say whether
happiness increases upon becoming a
parent
so if you want to know that you've got
to talk to parents they're the only ones
who can attest to it
because they've experienced life as
non-parents and as parents
they can testify to that experience but
a child free person by definition has
not experienced parenthood
doesn't know its joys and cannot know
what they're missing
as someone who myself has experienced
adult life both with kids and without
them
i would say that my happiness you could
look at it this way
my happiness cup may have been
you know nearly full before i had kids
but when i had them
the cup itself grew larger so there was
a greater capacity now for happiness
what i mean is i may have been mostly
satisfied with my life before kids
that's because i didn't know about the
deeper and greater joys that were
available through parenthood until i had
experienced them
the other thing about the happiness of
family life is that
you can access more and more of it as
you grow and virtue yourself which means
that as far as my case goes there's a
whole lot of happiness that i myself
have not yet accessed
you know because i'm still working on
the virtue part of it
um but any selfish person can enjoy a
vacation
and that's fine you know there's nothing
selfish about vacations those vacations
are good
but the happiness you derive is easy
it's surface level it's fleeting
that's what vacation is all about you
don't go on vacation to put in an effort
that's why
vacation is there the happiness of
parenthood and of marriage for that
matter
is found though through service and
sacrifice
this means you have to put in the effort
to become a better person and the reward
is that you'll find deeper and deeper
joy in loving someone else
because the joy there is a lot of joy in
loving someone else um
but it doesn't come automatically to
most people
you have to learn how to find joy in
that
on the other hand if you get married and
you have kids
and yet you remain a selfish spoiled
self-entitled brat like so many people
do
then you'll be just as miserable in
family life as you were before and over
time you'll be quite a bit more
miserable
and then there are people i'm not going
to deny that these people exist who will
say that
sometimes quite openly say that they
regret having kids
it's not common but people talk about
this they regret having kids they regret
starting a family
and what you're going to find every
single time with these kinds of people
is that they are very selfish and
immature and they never grew they
refused
to grow they thought that the joys of
parenthood would just come raining down
this from the sky they thought they
thought it'd be presented to them as
easy as that 27 cocktail
at the at the resort someone's just
going to hand it to them and they can
sip from it and it's a nice easy
relaxing thing
it's not you got to work for it you have
to go get it
that's the best joys in life you have to
you have to you have to
make your way through pain and suffering
to get to them and then once you're
there you know
second point though finally about this
label child free um
if you want to understand how grotesque
this label is that the media uses
casually child free well just imagine
how people would react if a father said
that his children are all straight and
describe that as
gay free parenting this is i got a gay
free family
it's great this is awesome what if
someone said that
he would certainly be admonished for
describing gayness as a disease you know
that you can be
free of like cancer and yet that's
exactly how we treat children themselves
like they are disease
that we can be free of
when of course they're not
and family life life with raising
children
immense happiness immense joy if you put
in the work
and so the child free movement
and the media that's uh promotes it
because they're looking ultimately for
the
extinction of the human race they are
all today cancelled
that's going to do it for for us today
and you know for me i'm not only a
parent of my children but
uh also of all of you sweet babies so
the joy for me
is infinite thanks for watching have a
great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical directors austin
stevens
production manager pablo vadasky the
show is edited by sasha thomashove
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
dailywire 2021.
today on the ben shapiro show president
biden accuses facebook of killing people
by allowing too much free speech and
taxpayer-funded npr targets the daily
wire for destruction that's today on the
bench bureau show give it a listen
you